leute ich glaube ich glaube wir haben
einen neuen favoriten auf platz 1 der
dümmsten züchter leute das kann man sich
wirklich nicht vorstellen als ich dieses
video gesehen habe konnte ich selbst
nicht glauben aber scheinbar gibt es das
wirklich muss ganz ehrlich sagen bei der
aktuellen geschwindigkeit mache ich mir
darüber sorgen wie oft einfach so hilf
mir folgen tatsächlich realität werden
oder realität sind ich habe ein video
über ein mädchen gefunden dass süchtig
nach sex ist auf eine hilft mir folge
mit der gleichen story habe ich schon
mal reagiert aber das hier ist ja diese
frau kann es nicht lassen
bis zu 60 self es am tag napster elena
trikots mit ihrem smartphone und dabei
verwendet sie fast nur filter oder ganz
ehrlich also ich kann mir das nicht
erklären leute wie kann es sein dass
permanent hilft mir folgende wahrheit
werden kann mich bitte einer sagen leute
also ich muss wirklich sagen das ist ein
phänomen was mir angst macht und wenn es
so weitergeht dann wisst ihr selbst am
besten was auf uns zukommt und dabei
verwendet sie fast nur filter oder
bearbeitet ihre fotos bis zur
unkenntlichkeit
die 22 jährige britin findet sich auf
diesen bildern einfach nur hübsch frage
frage also sie macht fotos von sich
selbst bearbeitet diese fotos dann bis
zur unkenntlichkeit kann man dann auch
sagen dass sie sich auf diesen fotos
gespendet weil sich würde ja bedeuten
dass es sich selbst noch auf diesen
fotos ist wenn man aber nicht mehr
erkennt dass sie es ist vollbracht
es ist toll wie eine marke mit diesem
filtern verschwinden
ich sehe nur noch süß aus deswegen mag
ich es so dass ja okay gut ja jetzt
haben wir einmal filter erklärt für alle
die es noch nicht wussten für alle die
irgendjemand über 60 diese videos weil
sie noch nicht wussten was uns fehlt er
ist sofort ihren vater anschauten
spiegelt sich die scheiße ausmachten
väter drauf denkt sich okay so ist er
tragbar warum das aber jetzt zur safety
sucht für das habe ich nicht verstanden
erste was elena morgens macht wenn sie
aufwacht der griff zum telefon delphis
ungeschminkt sind dank filter schnell
gemacht
ja ich wollte gerade sagen das erste ja
egal wenn ich es machen würde wenn ich
morgens aufwache
ich war als ich ich weiß nicht wer das
sehen wir ganz ehrlich
habt ihr hat er schon eine leiche
gesehen die gebürtige zyprioten lebt
erst seit einem jahr der nähe von london
in kontakt mit ihren freunden in der
alten heimat zu halten ist sie oft bei
cnet täter unterwegs also die da
wirklich ganz ehrlich was was soll sich
der liebe gott denken ja also ich bin
nicht über religiös ihr könnt jetzt
jeden einfügen die humboldt wenn ihr
muslime seien schreibt allein wenn ihr
an keinen gott glaubt dann schreibt
einfach nichts da rein leute aber was
denken sich diese gruppe an welt
erschöpfen ja irgendwann mal adam und
eva geschafft oder wird auch immer
irgendwelche anderen story und dann geht
der ganze mist so aus dass heutzutage
leute 60 self es am tag machen
das kann nicht im sinne des erfinders
sein ich fühle mich super dabei es ist
natürlich ein richtiger zeit vertreiben
aber statt spiele auf dem handy zu
spielen mache ich lieber selbst
das kann man nicht vergleichen
also sorry aber wo ist da der vergleich
nee du ich also ich zock tatsächlich
kein fifa mehr
ich zog auch keins mehr generell meine
konsole habe ich aus dem fenster
geworfen wenn ich jetzt mal so richtig
abschalten will nach der arbeit dann
mache ich bilder von mir selbst gesagt
jede freie minute verbringt elena damit
sich irgendwo abzulichten
und da die 22 jährige single ist und der
großteil ihrer freunde im ausland lebt
hat sie viel zeit fürs posten
also die frau wirklich komplett hängen
geblieben es tut mir leid aber eine
andere sache leute mir drängt sich da
vor allem eine frage auf ganz ehrlich
ich bin eigentlich mensch ich muss sagen
als überheblich noch voll was auch immer
ich bin nicht ganz so zufrieden wie ich
irgendwie jetzt gerade aussieht so mag
man ein äußeres findest gut aber aber
wenn ich diesen bastard von innen kamera
anklicke an meinem handy hat dann gehe
ich mir so
dann drücke ich auf auslösen und dann
sieht wirklich so aus als hätte ich auf
der straße eingeschlafen wenn auto
einmal quer über das gesicht
drübergefahren und die postet das den
ganzen tag für sie von sich die ihre
wirkung auf snapshot ist der mittelpunkt
ihres lebens alle freunde sollen immer
wieder sehen wie niedlich sie doch
aussehen kann wenn sie den richtigen
filter wählt also irgendwo ist das ganze
auch irgendwie eine ganz geile verarsche
so von unsere generation die so krass ab
geht auf install und snapshot irgendwo
euro ganz ehrlich dass die quittung für
uns leute also es gibt genug unter uns
wie wir alle wissen wer angesprochen es
die ein bisschen zu viel auf instagram
abgeben an all diese leute bitte dass
das ist jetzt die konsequenz und der
gipfel immer wenn ich poste denken sich
meine freunde immer oh gott sie schon
wieder
was ist bloß los mit dir warum muss sie
so viele fotos macht das hinter das
spitze das ist nämlich wirklich die
optimale strategie social media weil
ganz ehrlich läuft was ist der traum von
sehr vielen jungen menschen heutzutage
ist es ein sinnvoller impact eine
sinnvolle einwirkung auf die welt zu
haben ist es als ich einen
familienunternehmen aufzubauen ist es
anderen menschen zu helfen
nein nein das wichtigste könnte man
denken wenn man sich möchte heute
anschaut ist es berühmt zu sein
das wichtigste egal was für mensch du
bist egal welche leichen im keller aus
hauptsache berühmt und wie schafft man
es berühmt zu werden leute natürlich
indem man seine follower geisteskrank
zoom holt und abfahrt mit immer den
gleichen bildern das wollen die leute
sehen 60 mal am tag das gleiche bild auf
dem weg zur arbeit hat
immer wieder den drang sich selbst zu
fotografieren die 22 jährige ist als
buchhalterin in einer jobvermittlung
agentur angestellt also ganz ehrlich sie
hat drang sich selbst zu fotografieren
wie kann man sich das vorstellen was
soll man hätte die völlig daneben sitzen
an der bushaltestelle äußerungen bestehe
zum gaming schüler der bushaltestelle
legal fragt nach
insgesamt verbringt sie drei stunden
täglich damit den übersteigerten umgang
mit dem smartphone empfinden elenas
onkel und tante bei denen sie lebt immer
noch nicht als ungesund okay okay jetzt
kommt der punkt wo ich mich persönlich
bist schlecht viele leute ja gut
jetzt habe die ganze der sie befreundet
oder zu den dicken gemacht jetzt kommst
du dich zurück auf mich
ach du scheiße acht leute sie verbringt
drei stunden am tag damit fertig zu
machen ich zeig euch jetzt mal eine
bildschirmzeit die durchschnittliche
letzten bildschirmzeit der letzten drei
tage
ok ich sage einfach nichts dazu ich
brauche hilfe
dabei helfen die in jungen leuten macht
es spaß und sie haben was zu tun und es
gibt ihnen mehr selbstbewusstsein
so nämlich so so ist es nämlich leute
instagram und snap chat gibt mehr
selbstbewusstsein da ja sowas kann auch
nur boomer sagen ganz ehrlich die
allermeisten menschen sind normale
menschen durchschnittsmenschen diese
menschen sind auf instagram und sehen
wie ihre lieblings in kürze auf
irgendwelchen millionen yachten auf
santorini oder frau santorini rumcruisen
und denken sich so sieht er mich aus ein
echt und zwar kann sie von snap chat
instagram und co nicht genug kriegen
und doch möchte sie ihrem
schönheitsideal nicht nachhelfen ich
will mein aussehen nicht ändern obwohl
ich weiß dass ich nicht perfekt bin okay
dass das ist wiederum ehre und ganz
ehrlich da muss man endlich auch sagen
das ist wahrscheinlich besser als die
andere seite von mit dem eigenen
aussehen unzufrieden sein und was
dagegen machen nämlich die leute die
sich wirklich in schöner talkies
verrennen
meine ich nicht dass man sich mal die
brüste machen lässt aber so was sollen
die leute die halt komplett dar ein band
das ist natürlich deutlich teurer ist
auch deutlich aggressiver von dem was
man mit seinem körper macht insofern
leute im zweifelsfall wenn ihr mal
wieder einen schlechten tag habt und
euch einfach denker was bin ich für ein
kleines schweinchen einfach 60 saves
machen kein geschenk hier ein völlig
vorgeschlagen das video ab leute
abonnierte um einen kanal ich bin an der
stadt heraus wie gesagt macht fleißig
saves entscheidet übermorgen beim
nächsten video